de 15 à 16 dans le sud avec des pointes
à 18,19 et 20 degrés en méditerranée je
pense qu'on pourra à nouveau se baigner
malheureusement une petite ombre au
tableau il faut craindre que le ciel un
peu plus nuageux et là puis reviennent
sans doute dimanche pas encore de
certitudes et je pense tout de même que
les retours seront plus humide que les
départs merci lors il y à 25 ans jour
pour jour le 1er novembre 1954 la france
entrait dans le dernier conflit dans
lequel elle fut directement engagée il y
à 25 ans en effet commencé la guerre
d'algérie aujourd'hui à alger un défilé
militaire était organisée pour célébrer
l'anniversaire de ce soulèvement des
filets présidée par le nouveau chef de
l'état monsieur chadli en présence de
nombreux invités étrangers comme le
président syrien assad le libyen kadhafi
yasser arafat le leader palestinien puis
aussi la présence remarquée de monsieur
brésil ski conseiller du président
américain carter pour les affaires de
sécurité venus tout spécialement dans la
capitale algérienne pour rassurer les
dirigeants algériens sur les livraisons
d'armes américaines à leur pays et cela
malgré le conflit du sahara dans lequel
l'algérie est indirectement impliquées
par l'intermédiaire du front polisario
qu'il soutient contre le maroc une
poignée de main remarquée aussi celle
entre l'américain brésil ce qui
justement est le général vietnamien [ __ ]
deux anciens ennemis
le président chadli est également
profité de cette journée anniversaire
pour accorder une interview au journal
le monde sur sa politique un entretien
sur lequel nous allons revenir dans
quelques instants
ainsi donc l'algérie et l'on pourrait
presque dire la france célébrait
aujourd'hui le point de départ d'un
conflit sanglant qui est encore loin
d'être oubliés puisqu'un récent sondage
montrait que pour une majorité de
français
cette guerre d'algérie reste est
l'événement le plus important de ces
trente dernières années
l'histoire le prouve c'est évidemment
toujours après coup et arbitrairement
que l'on fixe les dates anniversaires
ainsi le 1er novembre 1954
l'intérêt des français ne se porte pas
spécialement sur l'algérie ce jour là le
dernier comptoir français des indes
pondichéry accède à l'indépendance
on parle d'un remaniement du cabinet
mendès-france et puis tout à coup
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée la
ville
ans se déchaîne
dans les gorges de tyrannie mines le
vieux quarts de la ligue biskra harris
aborde le kilomètre 18
il est 7 heures du matin trois passagers
du car sont abattues le caïd hadj sadok
l'instituteur guy monnerot et sa femme
s'agit-il d'une nouvelle révolte des
chaouis heures les aurès une région de
tout en contamine abl par les idées
révolutionnaires
pourtant la guerre d'algérie vient de
commencer dans la nuit du 31 octobre au
1er novembre 2008 à 7 heures du matin
des bandes armées ou d'attaqués en
quinze points du territoire où bilan 7
morts dont cinq européens
des dizaines de millions de dégâts
il ne s'agit plus d'attentes à localiser
et d'une action soigneusement montée et
surtout coordonnées de l'est à l'ouest
du pays alger des bombes artisanales ont
explosé à la même heure dans l'algérois
attaques de casernes 110 2 fermée de
récolte sont déroulées avec un
synchronisme qui attend tout comme en
kabylie dans les aurès et dans le
constantinois
on est loin des révoltes locales qui ont
jusque-là jalonné l'histoire de
l'algérie coloniale du boîtier marine
tête
il doit y avoir un chef mais qui et où
pour les autorités comme pour les
européens d'algérie une seule attitude
la répression le conseil général belge
et l'exigent l'ordre doit être fermement
et rapidement restauré les coupables
exemplairement châtié françois mauriac
prophétise l'horreur de ce qui va se
déchaîner doit être tout de suite
adoucie par une offensive chômage
l'ignorance la misère ils font des
réformes de structure et coûte que coûte
il faut empêcher la police de torturer
c'est au peuple que dès le 1er novembre
les joon-ho de se sont adressés peuple
algérien pense à ta situation humiliante
de coloniser avec le colonialisme
justice démocratie égalité ne sont que
leur et du prix nous appelons à
reconquérir sa liberté au prix de ton
sang se désintéresser de la lutte est un
crime contre carrer l'action est une
trahison vive l'armée de libération
il sent moins de 510 non pas quatre
cents à une foi inébranlable en leur
seul idéal politique l'indépendance
jamais en tout cas depuis 25 ans un pays
aussi proche de l'europe aussi lié à la
france n'aura connu autant de
bouleversements internes des
bouleversements pour l'édification d'une
société résolument socialiste une tâche
colossale puisque pour les algériens
même il fallait à tout prix à la fois
effacé toutes empreintes du vieux monde
colonial et bâtir à la fois et
parallèlement une économie moderne
capable de tirer de sortir le pays du
sous développement pour les algériens
d'abord mais aussi pour les français est
encore impossible de dissocier tout à
fait le passé du présent et c'est je
crois une des raisons essentielles qui
explique le malaise permanent des
relations entre la france et l'algérie
le président de la république française
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing a fait
le premier un voyage officiel en algérie
et si ce premier pas était résolument
capitale il n'a pas pu effacer
totalement le passé faire que les
relations que la coopération entre les
deux pays soient désormais exemplaire
lointain cependant après la mort du
président boumédiène dessine existe
aujourd'hui le président chadli dans une
très longue interview au journal le
monde affirme qu'il croit la coopération
avec la france et qu'il ne lit plus est
important l'amélioration de ces de cette
coopération avec l'épineux problème de
l'émigration des travailleurs algériens
en france
enfin pour l'algérie autre signe très
encourageant ce moment la position de la
france dans le conflit du sahara
la france qui s'est détachée quelque peu
du maroc pour a2p disons une position
plus neutre dans le conflit
autant de faits concrets cette fois
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont sans doute
tendre à faire s'estomper le passé pour
entrer enfin dans le présent coup d'état
militaire en bolivie l'armee l'armée a
pris le pouvoir aujourd'hui encore que
la situation reste confuse le chef des
rebelles un colonel qui fut ministre de
l'ex-président bender affirme que les
élections prévues auront lieu que la
constitution sera respectée que le coup
d'état n'a pour but que de remplacer
provisoirement un pouvoir lui-même
provisoire mais inefficace toujours
selon le colonel belge qui est le
responsable de ce coup d'état
le principal syndicat de bolivie
syndicat ouvrier a lancé un appel à la
grève générale
des affrontements auraient déjà fait
aujourd'hui trois morts
et plusieurs blessés entre civils et
militaires dans la capitale de la
bolivie la passe jusqu'à hier le
président guevara chef de l'état
provisoire n'avait pas réussi à mettre
d'accord les principaux groupes
parlementaires du pays pour former un
gouvernement
affrontement au salvador également qui
ont fait huit morts entre militaires et
manifestants qui protestaient contre la
junte au pouvoir
rappelons que lundi dernier trente cinq
personnes avaient été tuées dans une
manifestation
le gouvernement israélien a décidé
aujourd'hui après plus de cinq heures de
discussions de trouver un nouveau site
pour y transférer les habitants de la
colonie sauvage des lionnes m'aurait en
cisjordanie implantation condamné la
semaine dernière par la cour suprême
israël vous savez que ces implantations
sauvages en cisjordanie qui sont sont un
point de discorde non seulement entre
israéliens et égyptiens qui discutent
d'un projet d'autonomie de ce territoire
pour les palestiniens mais aussi à
l'intérieur du gouvernement israélien
rappelons que ces implantations sauvages
sont l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
monsieur dyan donna sa démission
maintenant quittons le terrain politique
si vous le voulez bien pour nous rendre
sur les lieux même à et l'yonne auraient
où se trouve notre envoyé spécial
philippe guez l'agitation politique qui
se développe à tel aviv et à jérusalem
est qui pourrait bien faire tomber le
gouvernement a pour objet un tout petit
quand deux maisons préfabriquées perdu
sur une colline un culte de cisjordanie
un camp minuscule qui fait peu de cas de
celui de qom des vides
un nombre grandissant d'israéliens ceux
qui veulent la paix maintenant a décidé
de s'opposer
ils étaient 80 milles à défiler dans les
rues il ya moins de quinze jours pour
dénoncer la minorité religieuse
les ultra nationalistes sont un danger
pour la paix d'abord ils sont une
minorité a filmé en israël
ils ne représentent que des groupes et
des groupuscules qui sont pris par une
espèce de mystique du grand israël qui
pensent que le sionisme c'est avant tout
le grand israël nous nous pensons que le
sionisme c'est avant tout le peuple juif
c'est à dire les hommes qui composent ce
peuple et le territoire qui a été
attribué au peuple juif pour réaliser
son indépendance nationale est un
territoire qui peut être tributaire des
rapports de force qu'il y a au
moyen-orient
ce sont ces baraquements qui ont
contribué
démission du général nyan qui pourrait
entraîner la démission prochaine du
ministre de l'agriculture pro religieux
et entraîné aussi le président carter
vers de nouvelles démarches
pourtant rien ici n'est définitif le
poste de contrôle empêche l'entrée de
tout ce qui pourrait permettre la
moindre construction en dur
le jugement de la cour suprême qui a
décidé l'évacuation du camp dans le
courant du mois de novembre attire les
journalistes du monde entier et tous les
habitants ont décidé eux mêmes de
plaider leur cause
ici c'est l'attachement profond ce sont
des racines profondes que tout juif qui
s'entend doit ressentir et son oncle
profond de son on vit ici grâce au
soutien matériel du gouvernement qui
fournit gratuitement les maisons l'eau
par camion citerne et le gasoil pour les
groupes électrogènes chassés par l'armée
une dizaine de fois les quinze familles
et les 60 enfants ont réussi à revenir
pour attendre l'autorisation de
construire ce à quoi ils rêvent
une vraie ville pour le moment la
synagogue elle-même est une tente
militaire ce que vous êtes des
fanatiques religieux
j'ai pas je n'ai pas le sentiment non
rien ce que je sais et je suis encore
profondément c'est que ici sont nos
ancêtres ont vécu et les tout par dc ya
à côté de ça il existe évidemment les
cheveux blancs je crois pas qu'il faut
il faut aller à l'encontre de ça ils
peuvent vivre avec nous
moi je suis pas de celles qui sont
décidés à les jeter contraire on parle
de la chaleur montante de la paix alors
la paix commence par une entente non pas
contre nous alors on attend que la fois
triomphe grâce au soutien des membres du
gouvernement qui jusqu'à présent n'ont
pas entravé les ambitions
en dépit de la décision de justice qui
fera sans doute jurisprudence
on reste confiant les hommes du camp
essentiellement des intellectuels
travail en ville à tel aviv ou jérusalem
aucune nervosité n'est perceptible chez
ces femmes convaincus de leur bon droit
depuis la création du camp il n'y a
jamais eu d'incidents avec les voisins
les armes qui équipent chaque maison
n'ont jamais servi dans le camp
palestinien l'entrée de naplouse
à moins de cinq kilomètres d'ici
personne ne fait allusion island
m'aurait même à l'heure où le
gouvernement israélien doit faire
respecter la justice sous peine de se
placer dans l'illégalité
la marge de manoeuvre est réduite mais
ici on a déjà décidé on est venus pour
rester mince il était remonté vous vous
pousse hors de vos roulotte
quelle sera votre attitude si dieu veut
une solution d'ici est beaucoup trop de
gens qui sont intéressés à ce que et le
nourrir est d'autres qui le sont moins
ils trouveront un compromis vous êtes en
ce moment hors la loi il faut que la loi
soit appliquée quand même en israël
d'accord il ya quelque peu changé la
loin selon vous ne partirez pas
j'ai pas mal et c'est je me sens juive
et en tant que juive j'habiterai six le
maximum
je vous rappelle l'ong qu'il ya quelques
heures à peine le gouvernement israélien
a décidé de déplacer cette colonie des
lionnes man ray le gouvernement pro
vietnamiens de tenon peines a accepté
aujourd'hui de participer à la
conférence sur l'aide humanitaire au
peuple cambodgien qui doit s'ouvrir le 5
novembre au lieu aux nations unies à new
york
décision qui peut peut-être changer le
cours des choses au vietnam et éviter de
nouveaux morts après les incidents de
ces derniers jours en centrafrique le
président de la république monsieur da
cau s'est adressé à la presse
aujourd'hui pour dire qu'il y avait à
plusieurs reprises fait appel au sens
civique des responsables de l'opposition
mais que selon lui les intéressait se
refusait à jouer le jeu de la démocratie
aient préféré appeler à l'émeute
en conséquence aujourd'hui toujours des
éléments de la force publique
centrafricaine ont pris place à
différents points stratégiques de la
capitale
par ailleurs on ne sait toujours pas
exactement où se trouve monsieur ange
patassé
le principal opposant à monsieur bako
deux arrestations de dissidents
aujourd'hui en urss en début d'après
midi le père iakounine chef de file de
la dissidence orthodoxe et madame velika
nova qui avait notamment fait connaître
le sort réservé aux groupes religieux
non officiels comme les baptistes ou les
adventistes dans la république
soviétique et puis ce soir un troisième
dissidents ont été arrêtés
il s'agit d'un dissident lituanie le
premier ministre monsieur raymond barre
présentera le gouvernement aux obsèques
de monsieur robert boulin cents ce matin
le chef du gouvernement est venu se
recueillir quelques instants au domicile
du ministre du travail et cet après midi
c'est le ministre de la justice monsieur
alain peyrefitte qui lui a succédé en
compagnie de son épouse il a passé une
vingtaine de minutes l'eau près de la
famille de monsieur boulin que boulin
qui rappelons le mettait en cause
monsieur peyrefitte dans sa lettre qu'il
avait écrite à l' agence france-presse
avant de se donner la main à sa sortie
le garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice n'a fait qu'une très courte
répond vous allez l'entendre aux
journalistes qu'ils attendent
je n'ai aucune déplacement à faire si ce
n'est que ma femme et moi nous sommes
profondément peinés par la fa trafic
ce drame doit nous conduire à nous
interroger sur la santé de la société
française disait avant-hier monsieur
chaban delmas le président de
l'assemblée nationale hier soir noël
copains l'éditorialiste politique de
notre rédaction expliquez lui que la
mort de monsieur boulin devait inciter
la société toute entière à s'interroger
sur elle même et bien aujourd'hui l'un
des responsables du clergé catholique
français monseigneur poupart évêque
auxiliaire l'archevêque de paris rejoint
un peu cette analyse il l'a dit dans son
homélie de la toussaint il a ensuite
expliqué ap ir alain quelles réflexions
vous inspirent est soutenue bien je
dirais trois choses la première un
sentiment de tristesse comme tous ceux à
qui j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler qui
m'en ont parlé ils sont très nombreux
depuis que ce drame s'est produit
le second sainte sentiment est un
sentiment de compassion pour l'homme qui
nous a quittés pour ce qu'il laisse dans
la peine et le troisième sentiment est
un sentiment d'interpellations à chacun
de nous à moi-même et je me demande s'il
n'est pas des mort d'homme qui sonne le
glas d'une société que vous et que vous
dites une société de quelle société par
les orges venir sans chercher de faux
fuyants la nôtre c'est à dire eh bien je
me demande je me pose cette question est
ce que nous ne vivons pas dans une
société de violence dans un monde dur
qui accule des hommes à des situations
sans issue sorte d'impasse je ne connais
pas les tenants et aboutissants mais je
m'interroge sur la manière dont un homme
peut être acculés au désespoir
que pensez-vous des moeurs politiques et
ul bien je me demande si ses moeurs
n'ont pas besoin d'être moraliser je
sais bien que le mot n'a pas forcément
bonne presse
mais je pense qu'il n'est pas de
démocratie nous sommes grâce à dieu en
démocratie et je pense qu'il n'ya pas de
démocratie sans respect de l'homme de
tout homme quel qu'il soit quelles que
soient ses fonctions
en particulier pour ceux qui sont en
charge du bien commun et quand je parle
d'hommes qui sont en charge du bien
commun il ne s'agit pas pour moi de
majorité de position sont tous les
hommes qui sont en charge du bien commun
et je me demande justement quelles sont
les conditions de fonctionnement de ce
service du bien commun car pour moi il
ne peut y avoir de véritable démocratie
que dans le respect je crois des grandes
familles spirituelles qui composent
notre pays et mon sentiment c'est que il
n'ya pas de vie commune possible le 101
commun vouloir vivre sans un être avec
les uns avec les autres et non par les
uns contre les autres
je pense qu'il est tout à fait légitime
d'avoir des débats d'idées et qu'il y à
des tensions fait quand c'est cela même
qui fait notre horizon quotidien mais je
me dis aussi que tout cela se situe à un
certain niveau et que c'est l'honneur de
notre démocratie que de nous situer à un
certain niveau et que d'ignorer tout ce
qui me paraît grouiller depuis quelque
temps pour m'exprimer en toute
simplicité
je pense qu'il serait tout à fait je ne
suis pas du genre pilate à se laver les
mains
il paraît impensable que la presse n'ait
pas eu de responsabilités mais je ne
suis pas maniche et à et je ne pense pas
non plus qu'il faille à tout prix
chercher un bouc émissaire à dire c'est
la presse je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que cela
et que c'est un problème de conscience
et un problème d'homme qu'il s'agisse
d'hommes qui sont bien sûr dans cette
fonction difficile d'informer
qu'il s'agisse bien sûr aussi d'hommes
qui sont en situation politique dans
responsabilités qu'il s'agisse en bref
de tous les citoyens
plus la situation économique est
difficile plus une politique sociale est
nécessaire c'est ce qu'a déclaré
monsieur françois ceyrac aujourd'hui le
président du cnpf dans une interview au
journal sud ouest qui paraîtra demain
matin cette politique est celle suivie
actuellement dans les négociations sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail ajoute
le président du patronat qui pose tout
de même deux conditions le système
hérité de 1936 dit ils s'opposent aux
réformes et la théorie des avantages
acquis illégalement
1 à la discussion avec des syndicats
monsieur chirac s'en prend également aux
grèves dans le secteur public qui selon
lui témoigne je le cite une absence
totale des responsabilités de ce secteur
vis-à-vis non seulement de la nation
mais aussi des entreprises
fin de citation les nouveaux dans la
sphère alstom l'intersyndicale propose
ce soir à la direction d'évacuer
l'entreprise dès demain c'était la
condition d'ailleurs posé par la
direction pour que s'engage des
négociations ça dit l'intersyndicale
ajoute tout de suite que l'occupation
pourrait recommencer dès le lendemain si
la direction ne réserve aucune suite à
leur proposition de dialogue
la grève des aiguilleurs du ciel
commencé en début de semaine se
prolongera jusqu'à lundi prochain avec
bien sûr chaque jour comme aujourd'hui
des retards dans les horaires des
différents vols sur les aéroports france
un incident à la centrale nucléaire de
bugey oblige l'edf à un arrêt de lusine
pour quelques semaines nucléaire encore
mais cette fois ci en allemagne fédérale
où pour la première fois en europe une
centrale nucléaire
arrive au terme de son activité vous
savez que les centrales ont une vie
limitée dans le temps et le problème
c'est qu'à la fin de cette période
d'activité leur démantèlement ne peut se
faire qu'avec d'infinies précautions
une enquête de donner ce baume au coeur
de la bavière à 60 km de munich de des
centrales nucléaires de l'allemagne
fédérale située à 500 mètres l'une de
l'autre
l'une l'isard fonctionne l'autre celle
de niederreiter bar vieille d'un an et
demi est en cours de démolition
ni de reichsbahn n'a fonctionné que 13
jours commencé en 1968 terminé en 1973
de type eau lourde elle fonctionnait à
l'uranium non enrichi et fut rapidement
considéré comme peu compétitive par
rapport aux centrales qui sont
construites aujourd'hui en principe
toutes les centrales sont construites
pour a une durée de vie d'environ 40 ans
c'est à dire c'est à dire tôt ou tard
toutes les centrales vont subir le même
sort et il est
pour cela très important d'apprendre le
plus plus tôt possible
comment il faut faire comment il faut
s'y prendre pour démolir pour détruire
la centrale la plus ancienne halle
allemagne actuellement a maintenant 19
ans de fonctionnement ininterrompu
mais il y a au moins une autre centrale
qui va bientôt subir le même sort pour
des mêmes raisons à savoir des raisons
économiques non pas pour des raisons de
sécurité mais des raisons économiques la
destruction de cette centrale coûtera
200 millions de francs et durera six ans
déjà les combustibles ont été retraités
par la centrale française de marcoule
les tubulures seront coupés en petits
morceaux mis en fûts et enfoui quelque
part dans le sous sol allemand dans une
mine de sel
ce démontage de centrales le premier
d'europe pose un énorme problème aux
constructeurs et aux démolisseurs qui
avoue ne pas très bien savoir comment
s'y prendre le mouvement écologiste
allemand attend avec pessimisme cette
première expérience
on s'est réduit de démonter avoir des
montages mais c'est pas des prototypes
vous savez imaginez vous que une usine
qui travaillent seulement quelques
semaines c'est pas beaucoup d'être
contaminés contre une usine qui
travaillent tes amis et tes années des
dizaines d'années elle a contaminé
jusqu'au front alors quelles sont vos
craintes pour la démontage de pas trop
grand nous sommes pas terrifier pour ça
ça peut arriver et je crains que ça
arrive à la quelle tonnes de matériaux
contaminés dans l'atmosphère pendant la
démontage mais je ne crois pas que le
danger est toujours en bavière existe un
centre pilote de télésurveillance
reliées au ministère de l'environnement
à munich
il donne toutes les 50 secondes les
bulletins de santé des centrale
bavaroise
prenons l'exemple de la centrale izard
dans ce petit bâtiment un enregistreur
sur son toit des capteurs l'un mesure la
densité de la pollution de l'air l'autre
indiquent les risques d'intempéries
métérologie et le tout est relié à la
salle de contrôle
si par exemple le capteur de pollution
radioactive indiqué 200 micro rennes et
c'est le détecteur météo prévenait d'un
violent orage
des mesures seraient immédiatement
prises pour éloigner les populations
environnantes
évidemment ces mesures sont rassurantes
mais la centrale bavaroise d'isar
subira-t-elle dans 20 ans le même sort
que celle de niederreiter barre elle
aura alors presque trente ans d'exercice
que feras ton de ce bloc de béton
contaminer les avortements sur des
femmes enceintes de 5 voire de sept mois
cela paraît à peine croyable mais c'est
pourtant ce dont sont accusés un
gynécologue et une anesthésiste d'une
clinique parisienne et deux inculpés
dénoncé par des infirmières de
l'établissement dans lequel ils
opéraient ont été arrêtés et revoilà
spaggiari dont les complices viennent
d'être jugés à nice dans une interview
accordée à genève à l'hebdomadaire paris
match monsieur albert comme on l'appelle
affirme notamment que ceux qui ont été
condamnés à nice n'ont rien à voir avec
la sphère du casse de la société génère
albert préjean l'un des jeunes premiers
des tout jeunes premiers du cinéma
d'avant guerre d'entre deux guerres est
mort aujourd'hui à l'âge de 87 ans à
paris vedette du cinéma muet il a été
aussi le principal acteur d'un des
premiers grands chefs-d'oeuvre du
parlant sous les toits de paris de rené
clair en 1930
un autre décès celui de mamie eisenhower
la femme du président américain le
général eisenhower morte aujourd'hui aux
états unis à l'âge de 92 ans aujourd'hui
c'était la toussaint la fête de tous les
saints pour les catholiques demain ce
sera le jour des morts la mort qui dans
toutes les civilisations toutes les
religions fait l'objet d'un culte
le film dont je vous propose de voir un
extrait a pour titre justement des morts
il a été tourné par trois jeunes
cinéastes qui ont filmé aux états unis
on n'est pas l'eau philippines etc
son thème la mort et ses rites
la séquence que nous avons choisi montre
comment au mexique
en fait là tous à domicile face à lille
comptait 10 mais il est bien de la face
coûté la vie à koutiala rythme pas
l'acheter talent d'abord leurs
trimestres ou alors si tu étais shalit
otage
ça va
les deux
là
et
non les témoins la villa
-
ometz pas qu'elle est aimée et valois
mortes et 40 ou à l'été la montagne
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma personne
mais hier à colomiers
tous
un militant no border jeamille bittar
on
les témoins la villa
voix
veillez monde
m
une fête de la toussaint à laquelle on
leur envie de participer
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui à
auteuil pour terminer il fallait jouer
dans l'ordre le 2 le 11 et le 7 ou
encore le 11 le 2 et le 7 je suppose
qu'il ya eu dix dit comment être dirait
léon zitrone à l'arrivée c'est à dire
égalité entre les deux premiers ça
rapporte dans l'ordre 1215 francs et
dans un ordre différent toujours pour 5
francs 6 ans cette fois cinq ans je vous
rappelle au passage que la vignette auto
c'est pas une très bonne nouvelle mais
elle existe sera en vente à partir de
demain
et puis je voudrais terminer par une
information qui ne manque pas de saveur
un malfaiteur de dijon recherché depuis
trois ans pour un hold up avec prise
d'otage du sérieux s'est présenté mardi
soir au palais de justice de dijon
le juge d'instruction occupé lui a
demandé la danse dans le couloir sans
être gardée par des policiers
le malfaiteur qui avait pris la peine de
préciser au juge qu'ils pouvaient très
bien revenir le lendemain puisqu'il
était décidé à se rendre quitte à ce
moment là le palais sans prévenir
non pas pour s'évader à nouveau mais
pour revenir comme il l'avait promis
d'hier matin 9 heures au palais de
justice de dijon
un bel exemple de malhonnêteté ou
d'honnêteté comme vous voulez voilà ce
journal est terminée dernier rendez vous
avec l'information hervé claude en fin
de programme
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à 2